Danke schön.
Ja.
Guten Abend.
Guten Tag. Ja.
Mein Name ist Uffu Ollara. Ich bin erst nach der Station. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahme-Geschbär. Ist das okay für Sie?
Ja, ja. Hauptsache, es kommt immer nach mir.
Okay. Darf ich erst Ihre Person schon da zu nachmachen?
Wie heißt du?
Ich heiße Claudia Thomas.
Frau Thomas, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 27 Jahre.
Okay. Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 7. 2. 95.
Okay.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Nach 79 Kilo wiege ich jetzt.
79? Wie groß sind Sie denn?
1,74 m.
74. Okay.
Ja, Frau Thomas, wie kann ich Ihnen heifen? Was für Beschwerde haben Sie?
Ich bin mit dem Fahrrad gestürzt vorhin. Es war schon dunkel.
Und da habe ich eine Baustelle übersehen.
Ich bin mit dem Fahrrad da reingefahren.
Und mein Freund war dabei.
Der hat gesagt, also ich wäre einen kurzen Augenblick gar nicht ansprechbar gewesen.
Aber dann muss es alles wieder kommen.
Jetzt habe ich Bauchschmerzen.
Der Kopf tut mir weh.
Ich habe mich auch schon einmal übergeben.
Also ist alles ein bisschen unheimlich jetzt.
Okay. Ich fange da.
Sie haben gesagt, dass sie für einige Seite ansprachbar war.
Sie haben gesagt, dass sie ein bisschen genau.
Er hat gesagt, das war nur einen ganz kurzen Augenblick.
Okay. Und auf welche Seite haben Sie gestürzt?
Ich bin auf die linke Seite gefallen.
Und der linke Arm tut mir auch weh hier oben.
Das ist ganz schwer.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Gansenbachschmerzen oder noch linksseitige?
Ja, vielleicht eher auf der linken Seite.
Ist Ihnen momentan schon ein bisschen schwinnig?
Ja, ein bisschen schwinnig ist mir ja.
Ja, Frau Thomas, jetzt werde ich unser Gespräch kurz unterbrechen.
Und ich werde Ihre Vitalperimeter messen.
Okay.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist sicherlich vernünftig, dass wir erst einmal Kundenbevorbe weitersprechen.
Ich möchte sicher gehen.
Okay.
Jetzt, alle Vitalperimeter ist unerfällig.
Vor der Urfall haben Sie etwas Ungewöhnliches erlebt, wie schwindelig oder...
Nein, schwindelig ist mir eigentlich erst hinterher, nachdem das passiert ist.
Kaltisch weiß, oder?
Mir war nicht irgendwie schlecht.
Ich glaube, das ist wirklich so gewesen, dass ich einfach im Dunkeln das nicht rechtzeitig gesehen habe.
Dass da diese Baustelle war.
Und dann habe ich wohl ziemlich stark gebremst.
Und dann hat es mich halt umgehauen.
Ein bisschen nasses Laub auf dem Weg oder so.
Sind Sie mit dem Kopf irgendwohin aufgestoßen?
Ich hatte zwar einen Helm auf, aber da bin ich schon ein bisschen aufgestoßen, ja.
Haben Sie eine Pirellung an Ihrem Kopf oder Schwellung bemerkt?
Nein, eine richtig... also eine tolle Beule oder so was habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Oder Blutung?
Nee, geblutet hat es eigentlich auch nicht.
Nee, ich habe auch keine Schramme.
Aber...
Also, ich habe so ein bisschen dröhnkopf, ja.
So Kopfschmerzen, ne?
Kopfschmerzen, okay.
Auf einer Schmerzskala Robyn, ein Zellasch, aber sehr stark ist.
Ja, sehr stark sind die nicht, vielleicht in der Mitte bei fünf oder so.
Okay, drückend oder stechend oder bohrend?
Vielleicht am ehesten so ein bisschen drückenpoffend.
Okay.
Und Linkseitke Oberarn.
Sie haben auch in diesem Bereich Schmerzen.
Rötung, Schibelung, Kabeln, auch an...
Das ist gar nicht so genau geguckt, wir sind gleich hierhergekommen.
Okay, oder abschuhungen?
Ich habe jetzt nicht genau nach der Stutthalbe, aber ich habe das nicht genauer angeschaut.
Okay, fra Thomas, ich habe alles... ich werde alles unterzupfen.
Okay, ja, Zihab'n, einmal erbrocken.
Das war plötzlich oder?
Ja, das war kurz nach dem... nach dem Ereignis, also dann sind wir auch gleich hier auf den Weg zu Ihnen gekommen.
Aber schlecht ist mir auch, ja.
Jetzt.
Jetzt noch ein bisschen übel, ja.
Okay.
Ja, Sie haben Koopschmerzen und Oberarn, Linkseitige und Linken Oberbau schmerzen.
Ja, Oberbau, weiß ich gar nicht.
Also mir tut auch nicht der ganze Bauch ein bisschen weh.
Aber auch die ganze Seite, also ich kann das noch gar nicht so richtig einschätzen, was da alles weh tut.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Hautfarbe, eine Änderung bemerkt an Iran-Propa?
Ja, als ich auf der Toilette war, da habe ich gesehen, dass das schon so ein bisschen blau wird hier an einer Hüfte und am Oberschenkel, wo ich wohl auch drauf fallen will.
Okay.
Ja, haben Sie Blutgezähe auf der Toilette im Irrind oder bei der...
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das war ganz normal.
Bei der Wasalasin ist alles in Ordnung?
Ja, ja, das war ganz normal, ja.
Okay.
Und so haben Sie Fieber oder...
Hab ich jetzt nicht gemessen, ich glaube aber nicht, dass ich Fieber habe.
Okay.
Ich habe mich auch vorher ja gesund gefühlt, also...
Zikon, an allen Geschichten, an allen Namen, habe ich recht.
Ja, so...
No, anigemiutun haben Sie bevestos, waren Sie bevestos, aber...
Wie ich da wiedergekommen bin, das weiß ich nicht, aber ansonsten, was vorher war, dass ich mit dem Fahrrad unterwegs war und dass da diese Baustelle war, da kann ich mich dran erinnern, ja.
Okay, gut.
Und Ihre...
Haben Sie Ihr Schlafprobleme, normalerweise?
Normalerweise?
Nein, nicht mehr.
Okay, gut.
Und ich würde gerne wissen, auch Ihre linken Oberan, haben Sie eine Verstellung bemerkt?
Eine, was habe ich festgestellt?
Verstellung.
Eine Fehlstellung, also ich habe den jetzt gar nicht ausgepackt.
Ich hatte ja eine dicke Jacke an und ich habe den jetzt gar nicht...
Okay, das ist ein Verstellung.
Können Sie alle Exemptaten bewegen?
Also die Hände kann nicht bewegen, aber den Arm kann ich nicht hochheben, das tut mir weh.
Okay, linken Hände, haben Sie Probleme?
Nein, die Hände sind okay, aber der Arm, den Arm kann ich nicht...
Okay.
Ja, hier ist die Algemeine...
...Allege, haben Sie Allergie?
Ja, ich bin hoch allergisch auf Bin-Stiche.
Bin-Stiche?
Da musste ich auch immer so einen Adrenalin-Pen mit mir rumtragen in der Sommerzeit.
Und dann vergleichsweise harmlos habe ich noch eine Allergie auf braunes Pflaster.
Okay, diese Allergie, du stehst eine pflaktische Schock wie...
Ja, da war mal sowas, was hart an der Grenze war.
Und deswegen muss ich jetzt immer diesen Pendant mit mir rumtragen.
Okay, okay.
Wie ist die Erkrankung für Thomas?
Ja, also bekannt ist bei mir eine Schildrüstung unter Funktion.
Also so eine Hashimoto-Erkrankung, das ist schon seit 10 Jahren bekannt.
Und dann nehme ich halt regelmäßig Türoxin.
Und...
Wie ist denn die Dondelung?
Das ist Türoxin 75, dann nehme ich eine morgens.
Die 75.
Und was noch?
Und ja, ich habe seit Jahren ziemlich unangenehme Wadenkremfe.
Da nehme ich regelmäßig so Magnesiumpräparat.
Gibt es dafür einen Grund oder...
Bitte?
Gibt es dafür einen Grund oder würden Sie schon...
Nee, es ist kein Erdenkrank.
Also ich nehme halt dieses Magnesium und hoffe, dass es davon besser wird.
Und eigentlich das einzige Mal, dass ich richtig krank war, war dann vor fünf Jahren.
Ja, da hatte ich meine kräftige Nierenbeckenentzündung, aber das ist jetzt schon fünf Jahre her.
Das ist aber nichts Krone-Schiff.
Sie wurden behandelt.
Das wurde damals behandelt?
Ja.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, geraucht habe ich zum Glück nie.
Nein.
Sie haben nicht geraucht bis jetzt?
Nein, noch nie.
Und dann können Sie Alkohol?
Ach, ganz selten mal, wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt.
Wenn wir mit Freunden da sind oder mal ein Glas Wein, aber viel Alkohol trinke ich wirklich nicht.
Okay.
Und wie denn nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich?
Haben Sie erforderlich mit dem Drogen?
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich mal so probiert, Marihuana.
Und hin und wieder habe ich das mal genommen, aber jetzt schon längere Zeit nicht.
Wann war das?
Wissen Sie genau?
Ja, da war ich noch jung, als ich so war, schon so sieben, acht Jahre her.
Okay.
Sind Sie postend gegen Corona oder Kinderkrankheit geimpft?
Ja, also gegen Corona, das waren Sie sicher.
Und gegen Kinderkrankheit, das ist schon eine Weile her, aber ich glaube, da habe ich auch alles, was man braucht.
Okay.
Und in Ihrer Familie gibt es wichtige Vorerkrankungen von denen ich wissen sollte, Vater, Mutter.
Weil mein Vater hatte jetzt kürzlich eine Herzbeipass-Operation.
Der ist ja noch nicht alt, das ist also schon ein bisschen doof.
Und ich habe eine Zwillingschwestern, die ist depressiv.
Depression.
Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter ist eigentlich gesund.
Gesund.
Ops, danke.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin liebig.
Liebig.
Wie lange?
Ich lebe mit meinem Freund zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, Kinder haben wir nicht.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ja, ich bin in den letzten Zügen meiner Studie, ich bin noch Studentin.
Studentin?
Was studieren Sie?
Pedagogik.
Ja, Frau Thomas, ich glaube, dass ich alle wichtige Fragen Ihnen gestalt.
Und möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder etwas fragen?
Ich möchte nur wissen, wie es weitergeht, weil ich mich wirklich schlecht fühle.
Was machen wir denn jetzt als Nächstes?
Ja, Frau Thomas, ich werde erst die körperlich ausführlich untersuchen.
Ich muss sehen, ob Sie einen Bruch haben.
Und deswegen brauchen wir auch Röntgenaufnahme des Toraks
und auch Oberarm und auch Kopfschäden.
Und wenn Sie meinen Fall haben, dann können Sie das auch noch weiter unterhalten.
Wenn Sie das nicht unterhalten, dann können Sie das auch noch weiter unterhalten.
Ja, gut.
Jetzt bleiben Sie überwacht und kommen Sie.
Ja, okay, danke.
Herr Kollege, andere Fragen?
Darf ich was fragen?
Immer.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Missempfindungen wie Krepen, Amiselaphen oder Tatwärtsgefühlen?
Nee, beschreibt Sie nicht.
Und noch eine andere Frage.
Wann war Ihre letzte Info-G-Agent, Tata aus Wunsch-Tag, nach meiner Frage?
Gute Frage, das weiß ich natürlich nicht.
Ich weiß das selber, aber mir auch nie.
Jetzt weiß ich es gerade, weil das am 19. August war.
Sonst wusste ich das nicht.
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Könnte es sein, Sie schwanger sind?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Nein, aber würde ich jetzt mal ausschließen.
Aber ist das eine Periode?
Ja, ja, aber es ist tatsächlich eine Frage, auf die ich jetzt wieder nicht gekommen wäre.
Aber es ist natürlich in dem Zusammenhang mit jungen Frauen, die nicht angibt,
dass sie die Pillen nehmen, muss man das schon mal nachfragen.
Können wir anfangen, als das geschickt?
Ja.
Guten Tag Frau Oberarsten.
Ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde Ihnen hervorstellen.
Hätten Sie dafür gesagt?
Ja, gerne.
Wie haben Sie denn gesehen?
Ja, es handelt sich um Claudio Thomas.
Er ist 27 Jahre alt, 79 kg schwer, 1 Metafilm und 70 kg groß.
Er kam heute seit einigen Stunden bei uns.
Er hat eine Linkseite geobene Verletzung.
Er hat eine Linkseite, eine Abdominalverletzung.
Er ist im Gefahr aufgefallen.
Nach dem Unfall war er für einige Minuten ansprechbar.
Er hatte Sinkob.
Er war nicht ansprechbar?
Ja.
Hat sie denn einen Helm auf?
Ja, sie tragte einen Helm.
Dennoch hat es eine Verletzung an den Kopf.
Nach dem Unfall hat sie einmal erbrochen.
Plötzlich erbrochen.
Ich habe während der Analyse reisegeşüpert,
mit einem Vitalperimeter gemessen.
Und alles war unabfällig.
Er hat auch eine Echimose an den Koksalberaş bemerkt.
Er hat eine Verletzung, eine Kontosition, eine Schwellung,
eine Lüchstattung oder eine Verletzung.
Er ist von der Patientin per night.
Er hat eine Hepertereose, seit zehn Jahren.
Er hat einen Trock-75-Programm,
und seit einem Morgen.
Seit einem Jahr hat er eine Muskelkrampfe.
Er hat eine Magnesium-Tablet.
Er ist vor fünf Jahren wegen einer Piollenefritis
stationär behandelt.
Er hat eine Allergie gegen Binnenstisch.
Das oisert sich durch die Anaphylaktischer Schock.
Deswegen trägt er bei der Adrenalin-Injektion.
Trägt bei sich.
In der Familie findet sich seitdem ein Vitalperimeter,
und auf Depression bei der Zahn-Irschweste.
Trauma mit Kopfverletzung und Oberarm, Humerus, vielleicht fragte.
Und auch, wir mussten auch Miss-Rübde-Ausschlüsse.
Genau, ja.
Miss-Rübde-Ausschlüsse, weil Sie...
Was wären denn jetzt Ihre ersten Diagnostischen Schritte?
Ich werde erst wieder Körper und wieder Vitalparametamissen, um alles in Ordnung zu
beachten, ob alles in Ordnung ist. Und auch ich werde ausführlich Körper anschauen,
eine weitere Verletzung, Kontizion, Schwellung oder Kriptation an der Humerus gibt.
Ja, genau.
Und dann werde ich nach einer Schwange auszuschließen, werde ich eine Rundgenau-Fnahme des Schadalts, des Toraks, des Abtoman und des Ober-Schanker-Links veranlasst.
Aber natürlich werde ich...
Warte noch mal, Moment, Moment. Was wollen Sie ausschließen?
Ich werde erst Schwanger schadalts schließen.
Schwanger schließen?
Ja.
Sie ist eine Gungefrau, deswegen Sie kann schwanger sein.
Okay.
Wir mussten im Blut eine...
Ein Interesse machen.
Ja, BHA-Test machen.
Und auch...
Duschblutung werde ich bei der körperlichen Untersuchung Duschblutung, Motoregensensibilität, Prüfung durchführen.
Das ist wichtig, genau.
Das ist sehr wichtig, natürlich.
Und sicherlich machen Sie im Rahmen der körperlichen Untersuchung ja auch eine Sonografie.
Ja, eine Sonografie.
Ich werde dann eine Sonografie düşen.
Bei der Sonografie werde ich Leber, Milch und eine Milch-GWB kontrollieren.
Ob eine Kontizierungszeichen gibt oder ob eine Blutung gibt.
Und auch Freie Flüssigkeit in Bauchöchle, Bauchöchle, Verdeichung kontrollieren.
Aber vielleicht, wenn alles in Ordnung ist, würde ich wieder, vielleicht nach einer Woche, werde ich wieder ein Optomareschutz...
Ah ja, okay.
Noch mal eine Kontrolle später.
Kontrolle später.
Mhm.
Ja, Blutbild.
By the way, ich werde eine Blutbild- und Blutgerinnungsparameter PT-PTZ-Inere, eine mögliche Operationen, eine mögliche Operationen,
bestimmen.
Ja, und mit Klois Blut auch.
Sehr gut.
Und so...
Wenn ich da also bestätigt, sie hat, sagen wir, ein stumpfes Bauchtrauma, aber im Augenblick ohne Milchbeteiligung,
Sie hatten eine Gehirnerschütterung und eine Schultergelenkstition.
Was machen Sie dann mit ihr therapeutisch?
Ich werde stationale Aufnahme, Zürich Beobachtung.
Und eine gegebenen Fall brauche ich eine City des Kopes.
Und nach 24 Stunden, wenn alles in Ordnung ist,
werde ich Patienten fernlassen.
Aber vorher würde ich Schmerztherapie durchführen.
Das ist wichtig.
Wenn es eine Wunde gibt, dann werde ich die Wunde versorgen.
Was brauchen Sie als eine der ersten Maßnahmen?
Nicht zeroidelle Antiromitika, weil ich erst gebe.
In welcher Form geben Sie das Schmerz?
IV.
Wir brauchen Zugänge.
Wir brauchen eine Zugänge.
Es werden wir eine Zugänge legen.
Schmerz-Tableten ist wichtig.
Wenn es eine Fraktur gibt, dann können wir das konservativ oder operativ behandeln.
Genau.
Das ist die Profanfraktur von der Agentin.
Was wollen Sie mit dem CT ausschließen?
Bei der CT würde ich eine Arachnoidalblutung.
Das ist eine weit sprachende Blutung.
Das war das, was ich wollte.
Sie müssen viel unternehmen mit Frau Thomas.
Ich bin gespannt, dass bei Ihren diagnostischen Maßnahmen rauskommt.
Ich möchte Sie mich auf den Laufenden holen und Kollegen dazu, wenn Sie Hilfe brauchen.
Alles klar.
Was gibt es dazu zu sagen?
Befragung ist gut gelaufen.
Ich habe die Präsentation auch.
Sie haben gleich reagiert und gesagt, wir müssen unterbrechen.
Das ist wieder ein bisschen unecht.
Sie hätten die Patientin ausgepackt.
Sie hätten geguckt, wie der Arm aussieht.
Ich denke, dass die Patientin eine Missrüptung hat.
Deswegen habe ich gedacht, erst muss ich eine Vitalparameter.
Das ist ja auch richtig.
Ich denke, das war 100% richtig.
Das war in der Schilderung ganz gut.
Sprachlich haben Sie noch ein bisschen Probleme mit den Fällen.
Das stimmt nicht immer alles.
Man konnte immer kapieren, worum es geht.
Eine Sache wollte ich Ihnen sagen.
Ich habe mich schnell aufgeschrieben.
Ich habe eine Sache gesagt.
Sie hatte einen unfall bestehenden Stunden.
Nein, das stimmt natürlich nicht.
Der Unfall ist nur ein Punktereignis.
Sie hatte einen Unfall.
Nach diesem Unfall haben sich die Beschwerden gezeigt.
Da müsste man anders formulieren.
Sie kommt bei Zustand nach Fahrradsturz.
Sie hatte vor wenigen Stunden einen Fahrradunfall.
Sie hat sich dann unmittelbar zu uns gekommen.
Sie hatte Beschwerden.
Der Unfall bestand nicht mehrere Stunden.
Das ist eine der großen Schwierigkeiten.
Ich habe schon oft darüber gesprochen.
Was ist ein zeitliches Ereignis?
Vor zwei Stunden.
Man muss es sehr präzise formulieren.
Ansonsten war die Präsentation klar.
Ich würde sagen, sehr vollständig.
Sie haben alle wichtigen Informationen weitergegeben.
Ich fand auch die ganzen diagnostischen und therapeutischen
Schritte sehr logisch.
Das müssen wir vielleicht noch die Kollegen einschätzen.
Das sagen Sie, Herr Gündrich.